I got a very simple [ __ ] question why  do people continue to think stepping on  people is going to get them to the top  you're going to get there when the  reality is what you need to be doing is  stepping up for people people are  [ __ ] confused out here on this Earth  you're listening to the wrong [ __ ]  voices you're confused by the situation  at hand you want to [ __ ] win get the  [ __ ] that you want you want to be happy  you want to be sustainable when you get  it you can keep it for the rest of your  [ __ ] life start stepping up for  people on the way through journeys of  Life try to help [ __ ] try to do good  even if you have a little to give  [ __ ] stepping on someone doesn't do [ __ ]  you [ __ ] out politicizing someone in  your company you [ __ ] hurting  somebody behind their back because  they're a competitor you're doing dumb  [ __ ] to try to tear someone down  God [ __ ] man